foreign
[Music]
thank you
Jonas
we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
foreign
we've got company
this night I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
the Apex Pro
everybody might get to the station
three massive mags and who knows what
else have escaped the breach
just hope it goes better than last time
what happened last time
you don't want to know
[Applause]
you've never seen this before they
hunted it back
you can relax this place Meg proof when
Jonas was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
foreign
[Music]